hey you guys movie retrospective time
here we are again talking about another
movie that won the uh patreon poll
by a landslide this is 1999's the sixth
sense good movie it is and you know okay
so
i have kind of like a conflicted history
with this movie i guess
i think the only time i mentioned it
previously was
a long time ago when we reviewed a stir
of echoes
and i remember being like really mad
that stir of echoes came out like
right around the same time as the sixth
sense and the sixth sense was such a
juggernaut
that it kind of buried stir of echoes
like underneath and in a lot of ways i
still think strive echoes may be a
better movie in the sense that it's
creepy or scarier
um but watching the sixth sense again
and honestly i saw it in the theater
when it came out
um you know and didn't see the twist
coming
um so and i thought that i had seen it
again
since then but watching it again
yesterday i don't think i have seen it
again since then so i haven't really
maybe seen it
since with you know with the full
awareness of knowing what the twist is
so it was really interesting to watch it
again to like recontextualize
the whole entire story and see how the
how the movie is constructed to make you
not
figure out what the twist is shamlin's a
weird director
he he ranges from great
to kind of like a uh
i don't want to say bad almost kind of
worse than bad
he almost sometimes comes across as a
hack
if you ask me but yeah i'd agree with
that sometimes he just misses it's so
bad
sometimes he's just spot on his
some people would say this is his best
movie which i can understand that i
think this is his best paranormal movie
some people will point to signs signs
was pretty good
but i think really the best
non-paranormal movie that he's made or
is the is the shattered trilogy which i
just ordered it
or it's actually unbreakable i got
unbreakable shattered
and uh split split split that's what it
is i haven't seen the middle one i only
saw the first on the last one
so i ordered all three of them on the
back of this i was watching this and i
was going man i got to get those
superhero movies
jamilyn's take on the superhero universe
even though i think that's getting kind
of passe
now marvel run that into the ground
really i loved his take on what
on superheroes yeah it was a real
original thing and like i said i don't
you know i've seen enough of his quote
unquote bad movies
to kind of know what i'm going to get
into but there's some of them that i
haven't seen
um you know like i know he did devil i
don't even know if he directed that one
but that one about the devil in the
elevator or whatever
i heard that one was okay um but i kind
of feel like after the village lady in
the water stuff like that it was kind of
like his name kind of became poison
which to me not really fair but that's
what happened well yeah
it's not but it's like it's really
really it's amazing to me how the sixth
sense happened because you have to think
when this came out in 1999
um shyamalan had done i think he'd done
like he'd written a couple minor kind of
movies he did like an indie film he did
kind of some throwaway comedy that
didn't really go anywhere
and the fact that he directed this movie
and it just this was the second highest
grossing movie of that year
after star wars the phantom menace yeah
second this was a massive
cultural phenomenon i thought it i saw
it in the in the theater it was a hit it
was a hit
and oh yeah it was good it was great in
the theater in 99 you're like damn
and really what did it was the acting
one
all right yeah this is had a lot to do
with it um
and then the twist and that's the thing
the twist was
really great on um on this one what was
the name of this one again again
the success makes sense the problem is
is that real quick
shaman became the twist guy and there
was one
yeah and that [ __ ] him up i think that
really contributed to his downfall
because
this movie was so successful like i said
it didn't only make all the money
but it really seeped into the public
consciousness in a way that a lot of
movies don't
i mean if you go up to somebody right
now and say i see dead people
every [ __ ] person on earth knows what
you're talking about yeah i kind of
checked out on shaman after that until
i saw unbreakable and i saw unbreakable
by accident
i can't remember where i first saw it i
think i saw it on cable
and i was like this is that dude who did
um sixth sense i was like god this is
fantastic
and then i tried to see the other two i
saw the last one in the theater
and his take on superheroes was to me
spot on
semi-paranormal if people were really
superheroes
what would they be like you know i mean
they wouldn't be like what marvel
showed you they would be mortal humans
with weird abilities
you know bordering on paranormal uh
yeah they are paranormal that the
paranormal abilities and it would be
kind of semi-horror
and that superhero trilogy kind of was
had a horror element to it
there were horror undertones and then
when bright burn came out
that you were primed for bright burn
by shamblin's trilogy breitbart came out
and
i like that too i want more of that but
they stopped making those
yeah well like i said there's a show
that a bunch of people have uh
recommended to us called the boys which
is uh kind of that kind of thing
yeah where uh superheroes are super
villains or whatever yeah it's kind of
like that
yeah so shannon was in shambler was
important in that venue
in that genre and in paranormal also on
the back of this movie
yeah and like i said i think for a long
time even though i really liked this
movie when it came out and i still think
it's a brilliant movie
i just i had a grudge against it because
it overshadowed
stir of echoes which needs more people
to see it
but i'm glad that i watched it again
because
watching it again i'm amazed
at how [ __ ] well constructed this
movie is
and i've kind of i was kind of trying to
break it down
and look at all the scenes and
everything because like i said the first
time i saw it
and it's pretty crazy like nowadays
because i think even people that haven't
seen it
know what the twist is right i mean i
kind of feel like everybody's
because it's just so it was so
ubiquitous and so many people have seen
it since then
but i i hadn't seen it since i knew what
the twist was so i was really interested
in like watching all the scenes and
seeing
how it all played out and how he
constructed it
that i liked this twist ending because
i see the thing the thing about it i
think a lot of people when they make
movie makers uh when they make a movie
with a twist ending because i feel like
that's kind of a big thing
the shitty thing is that yeah it's a
twist ending oh it's a big shock and
everything like that
but it's really hard to do a twist
ending
that you sort of set up through the
whole thing without people guessing it
and i think that he did an amazing
[ __ ] job doing that on this movie
because i think
most people did not see it coming but
then when it did come
everything like fell into place and it
made sense and then when you watch it
again you're like oh i can't believe i
missed all of the clues
that he seeded through there like so
cleverly yeah
um it was just like an amazing amazing
missing the clue
is what gives you the re-watchability of
the movie because a lot of twist movies
are not re-watchable yeah you can only
watch them watch well sometimes the
twist just kind of comes out of nowhere
like it's not even set up like they just
did it for the sake of doing it yeah and
then once you know the twist is coming
it's not effective and this one you can
watch see multiple viewings because you
can see all the little things that you
missed
and it's not only yeah and it's not only
that but i think
another thing that contributes to kind
of the brilliance of this movie and the
re-watchability of it
is like you said the acting performance
is amazing bruce willis was amazing i
forgot
how good haley joel osment was in this
movie that kid was
incredible and the woman that played his
mom too uh yeah tony collette she's also
in
she's amazing at everything she was also
in hereditary she should have got a
[ __ ] oscar for that but she didn't
um she got nominated for this one i
think haley joel osment also got
nominated for an oscar for this movie as
well
this was actually nominated for a [ __ ]
ton i don't think it won any or it just
won a couple
but um but so everybody did like kind of
note and the thing about it
is that it's creepy and it's a ghost
story
and there's like some creepy scenes in
it but i had forgotten how
like heartfelt this movie was you know
what i mean like how it was just
thematically the whole thing is kind of
thematically about
how people have trouble like
communicating with one another not just
dead people
but living people as well and it's
almost kind of like i really loved
um something that i didn't really pick
up on the first time that i saw in the
theater back in the 90s
was that bruce willis who likes
in case you're from mars or something
like that and you don't know what the
[ __ ] twist is
prince willis was dead the whole time
okay pretty much everybody knows that
by now so i just don't feel like i'm
spoiling it but his
journey um to accepting that he's dead
and doing
you know the things that he wanted to do
before he went off into the ether plane
or whatever
his journey parallels the journey of
cole the nine-year-old boy
who has been because he can see ghosts
but because when he tries to tell people
about it they react negatively
to it because they don't either they
don't believe him or they think he's got
mental issues or whatever
so he's kind of learned to keep
everything to himself so he doesn't tell
his mom anything he doesn't tell anybody
anything
and so him getting to a point where he
can actually tell his mom hey i see dead
people and i s
you know i talked to your mom and you
know i talked to grandma and i talked to
all these other people
and her finally believing him sort of
like opened up that line of
communication
parallels also bruce willis's character
dr crow or malcolm as they usually call
him in the movie
um finally being able to one realize
he's dead
and two um tell his wife what he wanted
to tell her
like before he uh you know before he
died and then he
like kind of passes on so i think that's
like a really cool
thing that it was threaded all through
there it was his first big movie i don't
know
i'm sure he made other ones before but
we probably don't know
yeah there was one i think there was one
that was yeah there was an indie movie i
can't remember what it's called and then
there was one that was like some stupid
like kids comedy or something like that
i don't even know you directed that i
think you just wrote it a lot of times a
director will
really his first movie from a big studio
is really well crafted
so you because they spent a lot of time
on it they want to put their best foot
forward
and this is their first and it may be
their last project
so they just [ __ ] give it everything
and you can see that this is a
well-crafted movie
the more i think about it this movie
unbreakable
this movie the uh with the sixth
sentence sixth sense
i always forget that because it starts
with a number yeah you know that's
probably
but uh sixth sense probably um it could
be in the same universe as unbreakable
and glass and shattered and all that
because he played split split that's
right because he could be
um he might you could consider him a
superhero
i mean that's what miss fisto would be
probably yeah if he was a real person
like this kid
i think this is generally i mean it's
generally classed as a horror movie
because it's kind of it's a ghost story
it's got like some creepy [ __ ] in it
i think it's mostly like classified as
like a psychological like a thriller or
a drama or something like that
which it mostly kind of is because as i
said i had forgotten i remembered
you know the twist obviously i
remembered a lot of the real creepy
scenes
like the scene where that girl like
shows up in his tent
and you know is throwing up and
everything and uh the one scene that
really got me
uh the first time i saw it was when cole
is like going down the hall in the
bathroom
and he comes back and he sees this kid
that looks like a regular kid but
obviously you know he's a dead kid
because he's not supposed to be in the
house
and he says something like hey come on i
know where my dad keeps the gun then he
turns around and like the back of his
head is blown off
and it's like i remember that freaking
me out really bad so it's like i really
like the way
it's a ghost story but you're seeing the
ghost the way cole sees them
and he just sees them like he said like
regular people just walking around
so you don't necessarily know um
so it's so it's not like this kind of
like ooh big jump scare or anything it's
like he sees a person you're like oh my
god that's a [ __ ] dead person
that's like really creepy and in some
ways i think that's like even creepier
than them being all like [ __ ]
luminous or whatever i think that's like
way creepier
and like i said i think one of the
things that makes it work
is that kid is just
man that that kid he i totally totally
bought
that that kid could see dead people and
his whole entire life
he was like so super [ __ ] up about it
because you would be
if you're a little kid he's like nine
years old he's kind of like you know
introverted everybody picks on him
because they think he's a weirdo
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and you
just saw like
really upsetting looking people and you
know that they're dead and they're
usually like all [ __ ] up you know what
i mean because they
it's however they died that's how he
sees them like because he sees this one
woman later that's like all half burned
and [ __ ]
if you saw that your whole entire life
you'd probably be a little messed up too
you know and so i really i really bought
his character so i really really liked
like the interaction between
you know him and uh bruce willis
character malcolm
who they're kind of like helping each
other move on
from you know the pain that they're
going through and i just think that was
really really well done
i mean watching it again knowing what
the twist is
one you should there's so many [ __ ]
clues and it just kills me that i didn't
get it the first time but i think most
people didn't i don't think anybody
[ __ ] called it did they
i mean maybe i'm sure there was like one
person that called it like the first
time they saw it they're like oh he's
dead the whole time
because i feel like that twist has been
done a lot of times since then
um and it had been done a few times
before that but i don't think it was
like a really commonly known trope i'm
sure it's been done now like a zillion
times
but i kind of feel like it wasn't common
enough back then that
a lot of people would have guessed
because i feel like most people didn't
which is why everybody was like freaking
talking about it
but there were so many clues the one
clue and i didn't even
register this one the first time i saw
it was that really really terrible
magic trick that malcolm does for cole
where he says he has like a penny in his
hand and he's like and then i put it in
my pocket but he doesn't [ __ ] like he
moves it around but he doesn't show that
that's where the penny is then he goes
and then it's back in my
hand again and then cole's like that's a
stupid trick the penny was there the
whole time
he says to him so there's there was that
like you know so the whole movie is a
magic trick where
the same thing you know the same thing
was happening the whole time i didn't
pick up on that
and then there was the whole scene where
cole after he's at that kid's birthday
party
and they lock him in that [ __ ] dumb
waiter or whatever it is and that ghost
like beats the crap
out of him or whatever which they don't
show and i think that that's good like
you just see the aftermath
and he's in the hospital and you know
malcolm's in there talking to him
and cole pretty much that's when cole
says to him he's like you know that my
secret is i see dead people
and he's like no i just see them walking
around like normal people and then he's
looking right at
bruce willis and he says they're walking
around like normal people they don't see
each other
and they don't know that they're dead
and then they do like a
like right there i'm looking at bruce
willis's face and like the fact that i
didn't
uh catch on to that is just that's kind
of um
that's what i mean about this movie
being like just this brilliant
magic trick and it's like i hate to say
it because it sounds like dismissive
like that but
you know because that sounds like that's
all it is so i was really glad to watch
it again because it really
does have a high re-watch ability factor
not just because of the twist not just
because
you're looking for all the clues that
are seeded throughout there which is
cool
but honestly the characters the acting
just the cinematography of it is really
beautiful there's just so many like
context clues
and he said something about because i
was watching a little bit of a snippet
of an interview with him
and he was talking about how the entire
movie they pretty much
shot it in these real like um somber
kind of tones
and they didn't want any red in it
other than um in particular ways because
they wanted to use red as a symbol
and he specifically said i wanted the
color red to be a symbol
of an object that had interacted
with the other side you know what i mean
so it's like you see
the uh you know the doorknob that bruce
willis character is trying to he keeps
trying to open and he can't open it
that doorknob is red uh the red balloon
that goes up
to the ceiling like before cole gets
that like scary ghost that's in the dumb
waiter
cole wearing a red sweater before he you
know interacts with a ghost a particular
time
so it's like they they were very very
meticulous
about the color symbolism in this too
and like even
said about it and i thought that was
cool another thing that i didn't notice
until i watched a thing about it was
that bruce willis character
is wearing the same clothes throughout
the whole
movie it's just you don't notice because
it's just like this kind of plain
you know blue dress shirt his kind of
overcoat or whatever
and you know the shirt and pants that
he's wearing underneath that was what
was wearing
that's what he was wearing when he got
shot like at the beginning of the movie
so it's almost kind of like hinting that
um
that he can't like change you know what
i mean because
that's he can't he can't like really
interact with the
with objects like with real objects
because if you notice the one scene
where
he goes to the restaurant to the
anniversary dinner or whatever and his
wife is there
and when you first see it you think oh
she's just mad at him because he was
late and it was their anniversary and
she's just being like she was just like
yeah [ __ ] you buddy or whatever
and doesn't talk to him if you notice
when he sits down in the chair he
doesn't push the chair back
he just sits in the chair you know what
i mean so he can't
interact with objects in the real world
the only time that he does
is when he sees his wife and that dude
that she works with
and they're kind of like gonna kiss or
whatever and then the window of the shop
breaks you don't see him break it
but you're just presuming that because
he was like so mad like all the
paranormal energy like did some
poltergeist [ __ ]
and like broke the window like the first
time you see it you think he broke it
like as a person but now that you know
that he's a ghost
he you know it's he was his energy was
coming from the other side to break the
window because he was so upset
you know what i'm saying another thing
too that i didn't catch
one i didn't catch that the uh the guy
that shot him like the
the crazy guy that came broke into his
house in the beginning of lunch shot him
and then shot himself
that was a donnie wahlberg i didn't
realize because his face was so
who's that contorted uh you know mark
wahlberg the guy that's in all he was in
pain again and all that that's his
brother like
donnie was the one that was in new kids
on the block i think yeah right i don't
know
mean i think donnie was in here on the
block no i mean
the band oh no the boy band no i never
seen it yeah yeah i was in the army man
i was overseas well no i'm just saying
that
donnie wahlberg i think was in that mark
wahlberg was his brother
but mark had marky mark in the funky
bunch and all that yeah that's kind of
informative later well that was well no
that was like 90s
so i didn't realize that it was him but
then because i saw his name in the
credits and i'm like wait i don't
remember him being in this and then i
was like oh yeah [ __ ]
another thing too that i had forgotten
about was that that character um
you know he ends up shooting him because
uh you know because the doctor like
failed him or whatever
and now he's grown up and he got out of
wherever and he like shot him
and i didn't realize that that character
his name is vincent
was pretty much just like cole in that
he could also see
dead people and you don't realize that
until later on
when malcolm is like listening to his
old
tapes and when he's listening to the
tapes of vincent when he was a kid
and then he leaves the room at some
point and then on the tape recorder he
can hear like this kind of ghostly
voice like speaking in spanish or
whatever like really low so
that gave him another motivation for
wanting to help cole because he had
failed to help
vincent who to him was kind of like not
the same person but he was like really
similar
so he was trying to redeem himself i
guess like before he died even though he
didn't know that he was dead
but it's just like there were so many
little things that i think
i really missed the first time around
see this is what i mean this is why
every movie like this it's good to watch
it two times because the first time that
you see it
you're just kind of you don't know
what's gonna happen so you're just kind
of like
you know trying to keep up with
everything and trying to make all the
connections and everything like that
but i think that particularly a movie
like this
that is so ingenious in the way that
it's constructed
and you know it's so ingenious and the
way it lays all the clues out like so
you can see
you know so so the end like makes sense
it's kind of like watching it again is
just
it's almost like taking a film class you
know what i mean because you can see
every single little thing in every
single like plot construction
and so that's why i think like movies
like this you definitely need to see
them like two times
but yeah so honestly um
i kind of feel bad because i think i for
a long time i've been
not bad-mouthing this movie exactly
because i remember really liking it
but i remember being really pissed that
it was so popular
and it kind of like you know kind of
bulldozed over
some of some other movies that came out
that year the [ __ ] blair witch
project also came out that year which
was also a massive cultural phenomenon
but yeah that was weird i never got that
one yeah i
didn't like it i liked it i saw it in
the theater um i didn't think it was
real
but um you have to admit that
movie was a marketing uh that was like a
genius
marketing i'd have to see it again again
because at the time
it was so different from everything else
i just found it to be unwatchable
well it's yeah i did not like it i mean
the thing about it now is that there's
been so many found footage that you
could
actually you could probably watch it now
because you're familiar with that right
even though i don't like found footage
movies i mean pretty much everyone i've
seen i didn't i didn't like them
i generally don't like them either but
i've seen some good ones and i actually
did like the blair witch project
it doesn't feel like cinema so it's
it feels like something else like a
documentary or something and i just
i just don't like to i just don't like
them i haven't seen it i
haven't found a found footage movie that
i liked
there's i have i have several that i
like um i tend to like
mockumentaries yeah i like those more
than
found footage but i have seen some
really good found footage ones
it just kind of depends on how it's done
and you know like i said i've kind of
talked about that before
but uh you know as a so so this coming
out the blair witch project coming out
it was just these two big like horror
movie juggernauts and i was mad because
stir rebecca's kind of got lost in the
shuffle
which is still a great movie and still
everyone should see it
but so i feel like for a long time i was
kind of like pissed off about six cents
i'm like goddamn you six cents like why
did you
why why were you so popular and like you
just trampled all the other movies in
the dirt
but watching it again i can see i
i can see why it was such a cultural
phenomenon well because like i said it
really seemed to
i mean because not only was it kind of
creepy um you know the acting was good
everything like that but i think there
was really something
in the heart of it that really like
resonated with people like i said this
whole theme about
um kind of communication and how people
had difficulty communicating with one
another
and in a lot of ways in the movies like
the dead people and the live people are
the same you know what i mean yeah um
and i think that that was really really
well
handled and i mean like for a
supernatural movie i think the best
ghost stories
are you know the kinds where
where you do this kind of thing where
you have this kind of heart to it where
you're saying something about living
people as well and i think this one was
probably the one of the primary examples
of that and that's why i think it was so
[ __ ] good i had just forgotten
how [ __ ] good this movie was and like
i said i felt kind of bad for like
saying some bad [ __ ]
i didn't say bad [ __ ] about it but it's
like like you said i think that it was a
shame too that this was
um uh shyamalan's like first big
movie and then after this because
everybody just
this got such good word of mouth and the
big thing was the twist
then he became known it's it's everybody
expected him to do that
it was called the twist guy yeah and
it's like and the thing about it
is that this movie worked because nobody
knew who he was nobody knew that there
was going to be a big twist at the end
they were just watching the movie
but if you're watching a movie and you
expect that there's going to be a twist
you can't really like relax and enjoy it
because you're trying to be [ __ ]
clever
and trying to figure out what the twist
is gonna be the whole time and you're
not really like
invested in the movie or invested in the
characters because you're too busy
trying to figure it out
yes this one came out the twist it was a
hit and then like his next two or three
movies
after this i don't remember it was two
or three
we're also kind of like twist movies
but they failed and it was because he
was known as the twist guy
and yeah that's a bad like [ __ ] it
wasn't his fault really i mean
maybe they asked him to do that i don't
know but he came across as kind of like
a hacked director for a little while
uh he made a comeback though he you know
he stuck around he made a comeback
um some people might say well signs was
a comeback
yeah maybe i didn't really like that
movie it was just okay
i liked uh unbreakable and science
didn't really have a twist
ended no no he stopped the twist thing i
mean other than
oh the aliens you know are killed by
water that's not really a twist though
um the only other one that i saw that
had a real big twist at the end was the
village
which i should probably watch that again
because i saw it in the theater
and i didn't love it but i didn't hate
it
you know what i mean i was like that was
okay um i didn't see the twist coming
necessarily
i don't know if you guys know what the
twist of the village is i kind of it's
not as well known i don't think
as uh the sixth sense one because the
village wasn't as wet i don't know i
feel like i'd have to watch that one
again
but it kind of suffered
from that too because i remember seeing
that one in the theater
and being like this is going to have a
twist ending so then i was trying to
figure it out i couldn't help it
yeah it just he came off after this when
he came off as a hack for a little while
yeah because he was trying to and like i
said i don't know if that was what he
wanted to do or if they were like you
got to do a twist because that was like
so successful but like i said the reason
it was successful was because no one was
expecting it yeah
the whole thing about twist is you're
not supposed to expect it once he got
out of the twist
thing and just went back to creating to
tell the good stories
he got great he got great again like i
said i got it i got to hand it to him
he stuck around long enough to launch a
comeback
and i could probably go back and watch
some of his failed twist movies
and they're probably okay to watch you
know
today they probably aged okay
but back in those days you knew it was
coming
and when it was new you were kind of
skeptical of the movie anyway
and when the movie really didn't quite
pan out it was easy to go ah
[ __ ] that but there's something about
once a director's been around for a
while it's harder to blow off his old
catalog
true i don't know why it's like you get
more credibility as you go
yeah and because he recovered and came
out with some really cool [ __ ]
i bet i imagine you can go back and
watch some of his movies that kind of
failed at the box office you probably
enjoy them
although i've heard that one of his more
recent ones i mean recent
relatively uh the happening i heard that
was
awful but i also heard it was awful like
unintentionally hilarious
just for being said i've seen clips of
it and it looks pretty bad
people say [ __ ] about movies that i
loved well i know that like
like i said though i'm not saying i'm
just saying that the happening is
one like a recent one that he did that a
lot of people
said was just so bad it was hilarious um
but i haven't seen it so i'm not saying
that
all directors are hit and miss i mean
[ __ ] sure
and lucas is hit and miss yeah [ __ ]
every over
everybody is i mean nobody can hit hard
out of the department
first time yeah and like i said i don't
you know watching the sixth sense again
really made
it kind of hit home to me i was like
this guy
is actually a brilliant director it's
just
a lot of his movies for whatever reason
um were not nearly as good as this one
and i'm not entirely sure why that is it
might not it might be entirely up to him
it might be
up to other factors i'm not really sure
it's writing
time budget on stream on screen because
he writes his own [ __ ] too i think
chemistry has a lot to do with it too i
mean
had you changed that cast around on on
the sixth sense it wouldn't have been as
good
that's true because they did actually
get i mean it was a small cast but man
they all worked together bruce willis
they got haley joel osment who was just
i mean this was kind of his first big
movie and he was [ __ ] brilliant
tony collette is always [ __ ]
brilliant um so
the fact that they got all these really
amazing actors in it
just not ex when your first time you see
the movie in the theater
you're just not expecting bruce willis
to be a ghost
yeah especially if you were my age back
then that's like you're going to see a
stallone movie it turns out stallone's a
ghost
you're not expecting that's alone to be
a [ __ ] ghost no one expects to
know that which is like 90.
you know yeah you're [ __ ] slow you're
old man
i like the [ __ ] seats alone like me
still
now i want to see a movie where stallone
is a ghost the whole time yeah
but well that's another thing too and
that's another reason why this worked is
because
it's almost kind of like and i saw um a
video pointing this out they're like
it's almost like bruce willis is like an
unreliable narrator but it works because
he does
he's not aware that he's an unreliable
writer he doesn't know that he's dead he
thinks he's still alive and he's just
like [ __ ] around
that's part of the movie that's what i
mean and it's like that's why it really
really worked
it dawned on him that he's a ghost and
you're going and you're going [ __ ]
you're going [ __ ] along the same along
with him going
[ __ ] dude you're a ghost he's going what
i'm a ghost
[Laughter]
i think that was my exact reaction and
then i was like [ __ ]
your ghost when that wedding ring falls
on the floor
yeah yeah it's kind of like get the [ __ ]
out of here yeah
i had to be there at the time well like
i said and
in a way i feel kind of bad for people
that are young
and are watching this movie already
knowing what the twist is
yeah because when it came out nobody
knew
and out of the context of the time it
was 99
yeah bruce willis was an action hero
yeah
okay yeah you didn't expect him to be
you expected him to be like the hero or
a detective he was a detective on tv too
with a heart-to-heart i think no
moonlighting moonlighting that was back
in the 90s back in the night yeah
moonlighting yeah
he was kind of a detective type dude and
then he was on die hard and you know
he did [ __ ] like that he was not the
ghost
yeah all right when that came when and
for the first time he goes
[ __ ] he's the ghost he's gonna [ __ ] i'm
a ghost
i'm not a psychologist i'm a ghost you
know you know
[Laughter]
that was the whole thing of the movie
that was the twist that they were
talking about
yeah was that minute you realized that
that dude was the ghost
and had been and had been the whole time
the entire time and it was because it
was bruce willis was part of that was
bruce willis if that had been
any other actor it wouldn't have had the
same impact
yeah i think you're right about that
because well and i think that yeah i
mean his
uh filmography reputation after that
point really played into
right uh why that movie works so it
would be like saying
arnold schwarzenegger was the ghost yeah
you just didn't see
he never saw that comment you know yeah
or the rock was the ghost
if you like that wait a minute the rock
was the ghost
you did you didn't see it coming yeah
you know
and that's kind of cool though like i
like it when when
with it when a strong actor like that
and i call him strong acting like a
physically strong actor
guy who plays heroic roles when he steps
outside
of the alpha male hero [ __ ]
role and does some [ __ ] totally
unexpected like rock's role
in pain and gang yeah he was a
bodybuilder but he was like a
bible thumper just a real jesus freak
yet i mean
and he's based on a character in real
life who was like that
and they they weren't sure if they
wanted to give that to the rock
because but the rock says no i want to
do it i want to do it and he pulled it
off
and i think that's one of the rock's
best roles i think so too he played a
bad guy who was a jesus freak
but he he was trying to help the captive
yeah and he was good-hearted you know
he's in jail though the real dude
but he and they're singing singing his
hymns
because that's where he was you know
that's what kind of person he was and i
think
well bruce willis doing this role was
kind of like equivalent to the rock
doing that role
you didn't see it really coming and i
mean the thing about it too is that
bruce willis i mean he
nailed all the emotional stuff in this
yeah because so many of the scenes
are just with him and hayley joel osment
and a lot of the scenes are like really
emotionally like there's a lot of grief
and there's a lot of you know and stuff
like that and he really really [ __ ]
nailed it so like
and i mean the chemistry between him and
that little boy were like really really
amazing too
i mean i think that really [ __ ]
worked yeah so it
like you said i think that really did
kind of uh play into it just the [ __ ]
casting in this yeah
and that lighting in a bottle and that
kid we saw him right after this we
watched another movie
this is tusk and he's in that movie too
we we didn't realize it
see see how weird that is that happens
to me that happens to me a lot
like a lot of times i won't really think
about it because it's like you know we
recorded
we did we watched the sixth sense you
know so we could record the thing
and then after it we said let's watch
tusk because even then
we've seen it before but i was like well
you know we wanted to do that for the
matinee show which you know you guys saw
the other day
and i was like i had completely
forgotten that growing up haley joel
osment was in tusk
yeah and he hasn't changed a whole lot
he looks about like his face looks
exactly the same
he's just bigger yeah he was perfect and
perfectly cast in this role he's this
little cute kid he was so
serious he's so serious with his little
haircut in his little teeth and [ __ ] and
his big glasses
are coming to see me you know what kind
of [ __ ] you know and
yeah he was just uh the right actor for
that role
i mean he was just so like i i think and
i don't even like kids and i especially
don't like yeah i mostly don't like it
and i
especially don't like child actors but
he seemed
so together and he seemed so adult
and as soon as you first see him and
he's so small and he has that little
face and it's just kind of like
he's so he's like a little cherub and
like your heart just went out to him you
know what i mean because i'm like oh man
that poor kid
i don't want to say i don't like kids
there's some kids that are cool just us
a lot of kids are demonic
in general yeah i'm not a fan
in general and wine and a lot and just
man
not get the [ __ ] up well like i said
it's you know kids
in real life i can take them or leave
them but it's just like i don't like a
lot of child actors
yeah i tend to like if a kid's in a
movie and the kid
is like an adult um but not like an
[ __ ] adult like just a regular normal
cool adult
then i'll then that kid will be okay
yeah i don't like
when they put a kid in the movie and
they're just like all snarky and hey i'm
a kid i'm a brat remember i don't like
that kind of [ __ ]
in real life though with kids the the
girls tend to be a lot easier to do
within the boys
oh big time but some boys here just like
they just want to talk about certain
kind of toys and airplanes and [ __ ]
that's easy to deal with it's the ones
that it's the ones that are just
constantly [ __ ] crying and [ __ ]
asking for [ __ ] or bothering you
trying to [ __ ] one-up you constantly
or ones that just constantly won't stop
lying
they got those types it's just you know
it's like people you know
it's just just like people you know i've
been well people
and like kids don't really they don't
really know how to be
like an adult person yet so it's like
they kind of feel like until they're a
little bit older they kind of feel like
the whole world revolves around them so
they don't really understand
right like that other people have
feelings or that other people have [ __ ]
to do or something like that
i mean you know i i grew up around i
don't have any kids but i grew up around
a lot uh i have three siblings
who are all awesome and they're all
younger but for a long time my parents
ran a
daycare so i was around little kids all
the time and i have like a million
cousins i was yeah i was
only usually only around cousins yeah
and
all my boy cousins they just want to
talk about guns in the army and [ __ ] yo
because that was in the army so they
won't talk about that but that's not
that bad
and the girls just want to talk about
stuff and show you things
look at this look yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
it's kind of cute you know but it is
yeah but sometimes you're just kind of
like okay
i got [ __ ] to do mommy needs to go get a
whiskey you know i mean it's that kind
of [ __ ]
i want to go outside but yeah so uh so i
really think that they really nailed
uh you know the kid actor in this
because he just he elicits so much
sympathy from you
um you know from from the jump just
because of what he looks like and he's
just so so serious
and he's just so he seems like such a
sweet kid
that and he's got like these horrible
problems because like i said if you were
like a little nine-year-old kid and
you'd seen like horrifying dead people
all your life
and didn't know what to do about it um
then that would be pretty traumatized
and no one believed you
uh that would be pretty traumatizing so
and and he definitely definitely sells
that
uh yeah so we have anything else we'd
like to add about
uh what well i'm just saying you know
what more to add about this i mean
i don't care what jenny says i think
this is right there with his other with
his trilogy
this character could be one of those
superhero super villain characters
even though it is a ghost story that
could also be a super paranormal
superhero story
that's like something mephisto would do
if he really existed talking to the dead
and seeing the dead or
something along that lines it has a very
different tone than
his trilogy superhero trilogy but
it could be in that same universe yeah
it could be
like you said it is a different tone
this is a very i had forgotten how
melancholy
this movie was which actually that's
that's not a bad thing about it because
i really like that
yeah it's melancholy but it's also real
hopeful at the end because like i said
they both
resolve their issues at the end and they
you know
they grow as people and well he doesn't
grow as people he just goes into heaven
or whatever it was
that he goes into the white lane you
know what i mean because he did what he
had to do
you know what i mean yeah so so i really
like that it has that kind of like
hopeful like optimistic sort of message
at the end
i was watching this thing earlier that
compared it they said in a lot of ways
this is almost kind of like the
optimistic
good version of the exorcist and i was
like
oh yeah i didn't think about that but it
is like actually really similar whereas
like this is kind of the angelic version
of the exorcist being the demonic
kind of [ __ ] cause like a little girl
that has to deal with all this kind of
you know like a little a little kid that
has to deal with like all supernatural
[ __ ]
my story is the real story of the
exorcist
[Laughter]
you weren't possessed by demons no back
in the middle ages they'd say they would
have said i was
well yeah i'm sure they would have and
i'm pretty sure that some of the people
that really were
quote unquote possessed it was
poltergeist rspk yeah
parents spontaneous psychokinesis yeah
matter of fact in that movie when they
went to go
test the girl didn't they just when he
opened the drawer and everything you
know what i mean
didn't didn't the two fathers think well
this might just be psychokinesis
i think one of them did use that word
although like i said i can't really yeah
they weren't sure if it was actually
because
he's like that wasn't holy water yeah
remember that yeah
she was scaring around you know it
wasn't holy water just regular water
it's like yeah we're just [ __ ] with
it right
that's how priests do yeah it's like no
it's just tap water [ __ ]
we got you
[Laughter]
yeah love it all right so
yeah uh the sixth sense is actually on
uh
amazon prime if you have an amazon prime
subscription you can watch it for free
actually unbreakable is on there for
free as well uh okay we'll probably end
up watching that one
you know unbreakable see well i got all
three of them i haven't seen it in a
long time but yeah i
i i'm gonna see it my blu-ray and
probably here tonight
probably yeah he got the whole trilogy
but yeah i was i was really really glad
to revisit this because you know what i
could have sworn that i had seen it
since i saw it in the theater but i
guess i didn't so it was so it was
really cool like to watch it a second
time and like kind of analyze it
you know because that's you know how i
like to do it you can get shambles
m night shaman's uh superhero trilogy if
that's what you want to call it
off of amazon prime on blu-ray from
delivered to your door about thirty
dollars if you get all three of them
that's a pretty good deal it's ten
dollars a disc yeah on blu-ray i like to
have my blu-ray man like a hard copy
that way they can't go back and change
any [ __ ] i got i got the original
i don't need their damn [ __ ] internet
connection or anything you know what i
mean if
hurricane hits me i'll just use battery
operated and watch the blu-rays
yeah there you go yep for the end of the
world
apocalypse movies okay all right so
uh we will see you guys on the next one
bye
you